déteste juste chaud et tout le temps alors comme
tout le monde chuchote pas moi,
c'est qu'elle ma maman dit que toute sa
famille est sataniste je t'aime bien tu ne
sais rien de moi
ma famille est différente de toi que nous
préférons le terme castor
quand j'aurai 16 ans mon  des pouvoirs seront réclamés
traitez la lumière avec l'obscurité vous pensez que vous
pouvez garder Lena si bonne si innocente
n'était-ce pas un dicton avant que je sois
réclamé et regardez ce que je suis maintenant je
ne sais pas ce que je serai F 75 jours restants
Ethan Sarafine la malédiction a déjà
commencé
Lena ne deviendra pas sombre elle est trop forte
elle va être plus puissante
que nous deux elle nous quittera tous n'enferme pas les
mortels son amie pense
assez longtemps Lena y mettra fin
Safiye est la  le château sombre le plus puissant de
tous, donc je vais être réclamé pour l'obscurité,
peu importe ce que vous contrôlez votre propre
nature,
j'adore ce garçon vous met en danger terrible,
vous vous ferez tuer tous les deux,
il doit y avoir un moyen de jeu  Alice aide à
arrêter Sarafine certaines choses ne peuvent pas être
st  opped - noix de pécan elle est déjà plus proche de
l'obscurité que je ne l'étais je veux que tu sorte d'
ici
il y a de l'obscurité en toi n'essaie pas de le
nier
accepte le chéri sois avec moi nous pouvons
faire l'amour ou un nouveau monde
toi